i'm going to try to pronounce your name
right yes of course
okay uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
uh mexico i was born in mexico in 1985.
i'm 25
at the moment yes and uh tell me about
your childhood you had both your parents
when you were young
um i did well i for at the age of three
my dad
said he's an alcoholic he has um he has
a
you know he's an alcoholic slash addict
you know he started using
at seven he lived in mexico you know um
he has used
any drug in the name of the in the book
um for him he decided um once
when he met my mom he actually um
decided to change his life my mom meets
someone who is
i guess a naive um conservative
submissive
mexican woman no um no drugs no alcohol
nothing
absolutely nothing um when he met my mom
i mean yeah when he met my mom he
decided to change his life
so um they were kind of older already
when they had me 25 i believe
26. um and
that lasted for three years until my
brother was born and that's when he
decided to
start his addiction again so in and out
of our lives
two years and he'll leave three years
then he'll leave
or a couple months and he'll leave and
um so i grew up
my mom ended up um kind of having like a
not hatred but
she's always told me that i look like my
dad so it's a and i'm the oldest one you
know um
i'm the one that resembles my father the
most i'm the one that um has his
character the most
and um he's she's always like putting me
like kind of outside
in a way that on all my brothers and
sisters so it's um
it you know she always like expected me
of me more
you know um yeah
did you feel pressure too absolutely you
know like i felt the difference between
my brothers and myself you know my
brothers and sisters and myself you know
you could see like the because my i was
i guess my dad's favorite i was a
daddy's little girl you know
like the oldest one the one that i will
go with him up and down but
yeah you can see the difference and i
always wanted to have my mom's attention
i guess
at the age of six i um i was molested by
my grandfather
you know i was molested um my mom um
when she found out she automatically
like knew knew right away i'm not sure
if her
her dad abused her because when i told
her i was sick i knew
i was the age where i knew from right
from wrong but i knew what he was doing
wasn't right
and i told her one day used to shower
together all of us together
and remember i told my mom and she
started crying automatically you know
she didn't question the fact that you
know what i was saying
so um from there my parents didn't do
anything well
i think that's what hurt me the most
that instead of like
actually solving the problem or calling
the you know the police
or saying someone with authority or
fixing themselves you know they decided
to move states oh
let's forget about it like nothing
happened right a couple months later i
get a
where we moved to united states at the
age of six um
a couple months later get a call my
mom's talking on the phone and she's
like oh they want to say they want to
say hi to you is my grandfather
um apologizing to a six-year-old for
abusing her i mean
that's absurd right um i mean i'm the
type of person that uh move on
with it you know like i i just you know
we forget about our problems that was
our type of family we searched about it
we're you know like i guess we just
we're a perfect family in the in the
outside but the inside we're
you know not the the best so i grew up
i was actually a good student you know i
grew up
you know i'm still here united states i
grew up you know very um
i grew up i love school i do i i love
school
at the age of 10 my my uncle from mexico
decided to come you know my
my my brother is my brother's mom
he the youngest one decided to immigrate
to the united states
and he was someone that was from um
no known well cartels in mexico
and um he came over here and um
he decided to he wanted to change his
life and he wanted to you know be a
productive member of society
so he decided to come over here and um
at the age of 10
he thought it was funny to decide to
shoot me up with heroin you know
he you know he um himself he was a
heroin addict
and he had the age of 10 he decided to
shoot me up and um from there grew my
addiction
you know like it felt right but it felt
wrong right
uh did you start using them yeah well he
shot he
um he like he will play around you know
like
and one day he like you know he i don't
know he thought it was funny there's
some sick world there's people he
decided to um
you know um strap me down like
handcuffed me and uh
you know with and decided to shoot me
and put her on because he thought it was
gonna be funny the reaction that i had
you know um from that girl my addiction
i started using then i'll see them and
you know
obviously go and ask my uncle and he'll
like he knew that i was having what we
call malia's you know
the come down or whatever you know um
from there i i i started using little by
little i started growing up my addiction
bigger bigger at the age of um 13 i
decided to get myself clean
you know well not decided myself to get
clean but you know like
my mom was like like you know she
decided to take me and i
didn't take me to rehab i somewhat like
you know um got myself clean i started i
graduated high school
um i'm sorry i skipped a little bit but
at 13 my dad decided to come back into
our lives like you know he was going to
be there and be president and be a
father of the year
and um from there he didn't he didn't
see me as a daughter anymore
he saw me a little bit different he i
can see the difference between my
sisters and me
you know like he um it was just
different
and from there like you know my mom
started growing a little bit more hatred
sources because she saw it swell
you know she she thought as well and um
at the age of
i graduated high school i actually did
go to college i went to csun
cal state northridge i would i gradu i
was
i did one year two semesters of
psychology and i was gonna um i did a
major
um minor i was going to major in
psychology in my own chicago studies you
know i was a good student
i love books right um at the age of
21 i i had my addiction again you know
i it like blew up again on my face i
quit i was a full student
working full-time and um you know i came
i had come a long way you know and um
i just decided to give i guess the case
of a [ __ ] it's right
and um why a couple
it's been a couple years you know it was
in a few months i'm sorry how old are
you now
i'm 25. i at 21 and start my addiction
again you know my addiction start at 10
and then from there to 10 to 13 that was
only three years i understand it was a
little bit but it's like
it came a long way you know i went to
college for two semesters i was like
going at it i'm like yeah i'm gonna like
bring my story to everyone and like you
know alex can
do you know like do get better addicts
can get better
you know but um at 21 is when um
i guess that's when i guess in a couple
months i saw myself back here again
you know i barely started like um
process twin you know since i was 21.
um it's been um like
from i never expected to see myself like
this again
you know like to that point where um
just
you know like i came a long way
for her to like just vanish like that
you know i know i can bounce back but
it's like
slowly i'm banishing myself you know i'm
like i can see myself vanishing little
by
little um at 21 22 i
i i was blessed to have a kid you know i
my son um he's
he's my everything you know he's two
years and a half right now um
fortunately he's with his dad you know
which is great you know i have a
great co-parent father you know like
he's absolutely great he was
actually like he was um he was who i am
now
but you know like the mentality you know
like he was an addict himself and um
he's came a long way you know like he
has completely changed his life but like
i believe i i'm a
i'm a i guess um religious person in a
way i believe in god you know
i do um but i do believe that i cry
like you know everyone here has a
purpose and you know my purpose was
obviously
obviously to have my son you know and
his purpose because he um he has
had an accident you know like where he
was about to die shot his patter
titanium leg you know
like and he's always he told me that
since he came back from that he he was
literally he wasn't even supposed to
walk he runs
and um the thing is that um you know i
think his purpose was here to
have our son you know like to protect
and take care of our son because
i feel like my purpose in life was in
order for like
if i had it took my my
my bottom to get him awake you know and
realized what he you know that you know
there's more in life you know
like there's more to it now like you
hear him and i'm like who are you like
you know it's about my son's safety it's
about
like everything's about our son you know
like if you heard him two years ago
like you know he didn't even care you
know like he wasn't even there in the
birth
he does my son doesn't have his last
name but now it's like a way different
man
and you know like i believe i do truly
believe that everyone here is a
faster purpose sometimes most of us have
you know
purpose bigger than others you know but
everyone here has you know like
we're here for a purpose you know and to
help each other to love each other
to you know to pass on that like you
know like that
human kindness i guess in a way you know
it might sound cliche and everything but
that's what i truly believe in you know
and you've been clean before you did it
i have i have
yeah do you see yourself doing it again
i know i can do it because i've done it
before
but it's like um
i guess um i'm just like very um
i don't know it's like my when i got my
son taken away it's like i
lost my identity and i've been trying to
fill that boy with men
i've been trying to fill that boy with
the drugs or whatever it is you know
like
um i have a like right now i've been
in this three days i've only been using
like not not as much as
i do you know like like right now i
wanted to like you know use but
my friend over here he was like no it's
not gonna happen
stop thinking about the pipe and i'm
just like no like please
you know and um it's like you know i
have there's more
things in life than that but i
understand you know sometimes people get
um
lost you know people get confused you
know
i had i have released principles and you
know and um
and you know values but within
you know within this with within other
people i got confused you know and you
tend to
forget your values and your beliefs you
know it's like
but now um i'm very grateful for the
people that have come across you know
in my life because they have directed me
again and you know
motivate myself again and um you know
hopefully i
i do believe that i am you know my son
didn't go through all this for nothing
you know
uh he's either meant to be with me or
meant to be with his father
and um either or you know like
god is just has justice you know like so
i know that
like this happened for me to like be a
little more grateful for [ __ ] you know
like
i am a very selfish person but
yeah what what emotions do you deal with
it sounds like
being apart from your son is is guilt
shame it's got to be hard for a mother
right
yeah okay um it's not even that it's
like
the fact that um what my son went
through you know like
his pain not my pain his pain like my
son
um when i had him i completely stopped
when i found out that i was pregnant i
completely stopped
i found out that i was pregnant three
months and i completely stopped i
i um you know i had another life going
on me like that's
like that's amazing you know like
the like you know what a woman can do
and you know like
just knowing that you're like it's just
the bond that's created that's you know
that's unconditional love right there
like that's the first time that i felt
love in my life when i held my son you
know
you know sorry
your story clearly shows the power of
addiction because it's obvious
that you want to be with your son and be
there for him and yet you're
you're you're stuck here
i guess i've been stuck in this
mentality where i know he's okay but
it's like i'm torn apart like sometimes
i do um
there's things where i'm like i'm
motivated right
i'm motivated too thank you i'm
motivated
to get i know my son is okay you know i
know my son is saved but i know he needs
his mother as well you know
and i'm torn between this um i can't
stop it's like
why can't i stop and it's so simple why
can't i stop like
i'm making myself i'm i make it hard
myself you know
we complicate our lives you know it's so
simple to just say one day
let's stop you know but it's like
i i'm not i'm not because i like to mix
in
the street smart and the book smart
right to see what really like
goes to the root of it and finally just
get over it you know
but i can't seem to um
to like you know figure out what really
is wrong you know because um
it's just it's really hard and i do
understand everyone around here you know
like
but as long as you keep yourself you
know like i still keep my mentality and
my values
my principles yet um it's more powerful
than you it's more powerful
but yet like you know unless you find a
balance between your mind
and your mindset in your heart you're
never gonna you know be able to overcome
whatever like you know
whatever is it that's you know you're
fighting in life you don't
like when i'm fighting with my addiction
you might be fighting with something
else you know like
everyone fights with their own demons in
you know different perspectives but
unless you find you don't find a
balance between this the mindset and the
heart but um a lot of people think with
this
and a lot of people are scandalous and a
lot of people are hurtful and sick and
you know
mean but you always have to go with this
you know your heart
you know a lot of people tend to forget
you know um that we are humans
and you know a lot of people tend to
forget you know to give kindness
you know and as long as you give that
enough we stay humble you know
you know we say with your true answers
you're gonna be okay you know
what do you think set you on this path
as a child was it
was it something from your childhood
like no i believe that i was i'm not
here at the right moment at the right
place because
destiny or god wants it to be you know
um you know i'm here maybe like i told
you um
maybe me being here made the father my
son
snap out of it embraced he's he was able
to get herself
back from foster you know like
that's amazing you know um he's doing
what i'm supposed to be doing
uh maybe i'm here to teach someone else
you know
maybe the death of someone is in order
to teach someone else something
you know or to like change someone's
life or
you know like a lot of people like you
know we have we're here for a purpose my
purpose might be bigger than yours
or you know his purpose might be bigger
than his you know maybe my purpose is to
protect him because his purpose
is meant to do greater things you know
what's been the lowest point of your
life is it kind of what you're going
through right now
accepting the fact that i was gonna be
okay that i was gonna be i'm i wasn't
gonna have my son
that was the lowest point accepting the
fact that i wasn't gonna have my son
then my son
i'm never i was never gonna see my son
that he was gonna be okay without my
life
with me without me that's the lowest
point
so where do you stay now right now i do
stay in the tent i stay in the tent with
uh
an acquaintance of mine um yes he's
helping me out at the moment
you know we do want to get out of
eventually out of this place you know
he helps me and i help him it's nothing
more than that um
he's a very good friend of mine actually
how do you find skid row as a
place to live living on the street in
skid row is not not for everyone right
it's it's not what i'm used to it's not
what i grew up in but it's
you know i have it i found it to respect
it you know like
you don't know anyone's story you know
you don't know you know her his
you know like everyone here has a
different story you know and you know it
got um
you know i see everyone around here and
i'm like i wonder what like you know
that person went through i wonder what
let let them to be at this point in
their life you know
and um i see myself like
you know at some point you get
comfortable with stuff you know like oh
you get comfortable with sleeping you
know in the car
for the night or like not taking a
shower or two nothing and then you find
yourself here and then
i understand why you start getting
comfortable with stuff you know like
you start being okay with it and um you
know
sometimes unfortunately like people get
stuck with it you know
people don't you know react they get
confused and don't you know
don't get back to their to their selves
like i'm grateful
you know that i i am blessed and
grateful to actually have you know still
my minds that you know to still have
that
you know because i i got to the stage
where i got you know
insane you know like when i thought that
i wasn't going to come back mentally you
know
and you know every time that i do take a
hit or take a shot i
i am grateful that you know i'm able to
come back because you know i see
sometimes
people on the on the street screaming or
you know delusional and i'm like that
can be me
the next hit that i take that can be me
you know that can be
me next time and you know i'm very
grateful that i'm here you know do you
worry
as a as a heroin addict do you worry
about fentanyl
i don't actually don't you know like
i heard you know around that that's
going going around and it's like
it's scary but yet i trust the people
that i you know that give it to me in a
way
because i still do it i mean honestly as
an addict
you don't you don't care like you just
want you care about your next hit your
next job you that's all you care about
that's all you're feeling about a lot of
people are dying and a lot of people are
passing away you know
a lot and it's just like oh it's okay
like
man it's just you know you know you
don't really
give it a thought you know you don't
that's not the first thing you think
like
when you're getting your setup do your
thing ready and
you're like oh [ __ ] maybe this this has
like been on there
[ __ ] what do i do i still take it though
so like you know it's not the first
thing you think about
you know and and so the way you're
supporting yourself now
working as a prostitute that that can't
be easy well
it's it's okay i mean it's not nothing
like
my it's nothing of the other world it's
not a taboo i guess you know
a lot of women here is do the same you
know most of them most of them
yeah like maybe 95 percent of the time
the 99 percent guys too
but i'm sorry and some of the guys too
yeah as well yeah absolutely a lot of
the guys i think
absolutely but it's like it's um i guess
it's a job i guess i don't know i i mean
i
i guess i came to become normal with it
you know it's just became a normal thing
i i really don't see nothing wrong with
it
which i maybe should but it's just you
know i'm trying to survive
that's what i'm trying to do you know i
know that i
do i had to have a kid that i have to um
you know i do i am
financially there somewhat
you know i do and i try to like you know
my sensibility is better like the most
important
my sensibility um and safety is the
you know the priority for me what's the
most important lesson you've learned
to always stay true to yourself you know
to always you know
um you know to not let anyone change
your you know your principles and values
and perspective in life
you know to not question them because
when once you start questioning your own
beliefs
then that's when things go wrong you
know
all right cat well thank you so much for
sharing your story and i wish you
all the luck in the world thank you i
appreciate it thank you for listening to
yeah that would be nice to get off get
cleaning from heroin again right
absolutely it would be great for you
thank you thank you very much